so what do you get to do with the most
powerful dark wizard in the history of
the series well break
things seriously that's the whole point
of the level you run around this city
and while you can crucio or even AK the
Frantic citizens attempting to flee
that's not how you actually complete the
level to complete it you need to collect
1 million studs which would happen in
seconds if you could use the red brick
multipliers but here no multipliers so
what this results in is a mission where
you have to spam the square button
repeatedly for about 15 minutes straight
while waiting for the studs to surpass
the 1 million Mark actually thought
about offering my two boys $5 each to
just take turns spamming the square
button seriously that's the level of
desperation I had at this point honestly
they would have probably enjoyed it but
I did power through on my own and after
what felt like an eternity I had
completed the level to finally unlock Mr
Snake NOS himself